[Music]
you are by far the most
excruciating difficult stubbornly
obnoxious woman i've ever met in my
entire
life i [ __ ] love you how are y'all
doing first of all
i just have to say this movie is so so
so good
you guys should be incredibly proud both
as producers
as actors and as the awards editor at
rotten tomatoes i have a feeling i'll be
writing a lot of coffee about this movie
this movie i think for you and marie it
might be the first
time that you've actually gotten to be
like angry
like and really just yell at this
gentleman for two weeks in a row so
talk about talk about how fun that was
and
you mentioned how like you know rue got
kind of pulled out from under you
and you were already in her headspace so
how did you switch to get into the head
space of marie
right shout out to your beyonce candle
first of all um
we love to see it yes i was in the
headspace geared up ready for
uh fourroux um and with that being said
it was going to be a very difficult very
taxing
uh season and uh i had missed
her so much like i and when i get into
she just i just kind of fall into her
you know and
but magically somehow as as marie was
being written
uh and sam would write these pages and
then he'd
you know read them to me and we'd talk
for hours i would record him because
he just he he had this cadence that i
felt was perfect already and marie was
already being found and i think it's
because it's
part sam marie's part somebody's also
he wrote her i mean he wrote these
characters for us but he wrote them
with i think um he wrote it to
the zendaya the grown woman that i'm you
know becoming and he's watching you know
kind of
become in front of his eyes and so i
think that that
had a lot to do with it so it felt like
she really was already just kind of
forming
in front of my eyes and it was really
just my job to kind of
release her to a degree um and
i don't know i think as far as being
angry i i'm not
it's interesting because i'm a i do i
can argue which is like i i
but not in a yelly kind of way you know
what i mean
i'm a debater you know i typically raise
my voice or yell at anybody and i found
that difficult even with
with rue when you know she'd have to
have these screaming matches with her
mother
um it was it was extremely draining but
for some reason
when it was marie it felt uh
like therapeutic like right like getting
it out it didn't even drain me it felt
like empowering almost it was just like
hell yeah
you know what i mean it felt like
something i needed to get off my chest
and i don't know if that was because i
hadn't been able
to act that past year i don't know if i
was just
um so excited to be you know whatever
you let out
from john david and he was just like
giving me so much as an actor to work
with and bounce
off of um and i just was so grateful to
be there
uh that it was just like yeah i like it
you it was really just became a funnel
to take whatever feelings i had over the
past year and just
push them out through this through this
uh through this woman
excellent well john david washington i
have to say you gave it
as good as you got let's be honest it
was
incredible to watch what you did on
screen
but i think like it says it in the
trailer this isn't a love story this is
a story about
love and these are two very flawed
people so i'm just curious
do you think imperfect people can find a
perfect love or do you think that these
two should just like
not be a couple what is perfect love i
mean i i
i find myself constantly trying to work
on myself
i find like i'm constantly trying to
work on myself and i don't want my
partner
to have to feel that extra percent you
know if i'm like
60 knowing who i am i that feels better
than being 50 percent
depending on that other 50 to make me
whole you know so
i think i think they both need to work
on themselves
you know then maybe they can use some
counseling and we'll see maybe maybe
they can figure some things out because
uh no matter good or bad
their relationship will never be the
same after a night like that
it just won't so um i i i wish them well
um i think in moments they're just they
are perfect for each other in other
moments they need
they need some space or they need a
referee i'm sorry
[Music]
tell me why it hurts uh sam
you are the person i wanted to talk to
since i've seen this movie sir let me
tell you but first of all
seriously congratulations about it it's
it's really incredible
as you already know i mean what's crazy
about is this basically started
out of you and zendaya playing like i
guess text and phone
i'm bored what are you doing and you're
like let's make a movie
and then we got this but i'm also
curious before we talk about those
conversations
what is something random that you two
were sort of like bsing about
before you decided to go make a movie
something random
that people would be surprised that
y'all be talking about
i don't know we kind of talk i mean look
especially at that time when it was like
we were a day away from shooting season
two of euphoria
so you know she was like
ready to go in as rue it's a pretty
messy season for roe
um you know so we were just
i don't know we just hop on the phone
and we just we're just kind of kicking
around different things i i don't know
something random
i i can't necessarily think of something
awesome did you recommend a movie to her
that maybe she was just like
ugh about because i've heard that
sometimes oh i'm always recommending
movies to her
um i was just recommending that i was
like you need to watch to die for
you you have to watch to die for it's
one of the greatest
films in the last 30 years it's so you
know
uh it's so prescient in so many
different ways
awesome well bringing it back to the
movie i just first i have to say again
congratulations
i like that you took a very embarrassing
moment
for yourself and made it into artistic
greatness
i really do hope uh your wife forgives
you but
i'm just curious like did it feel weird
putting such a personal thing
into this and i also want to know if it
was the sundance premiere where you
forgot because i was at that one
you know i think we never had a fight
about it um we only talked about it i
think on the car ride home
and it was a pretty like it was a pretty
easy thoughtful conversation but it did
spark in me this idea of what happens
when you don't acknowledge your
your the the people in your life that
you love
that um uh that uh uh
you know and and what happens
particularly in
in filmmaking when you're not
acknowledging the contributions
of of each other this was actually the
first movie that
um that she produced uh alongside me
um and so you know i just
i like that as a jumping off point um
but
it wasn't uh you know but this kind of
the the dialogue and the dynamics
between the characters
was more of just like a a strange kind
of
you know socratic dialogue of just
malcolm
coming in drunk just going off on things
and then marie just slowly poking holes
in it and then back and forth
going for the jugular waking up you know
and i would just try to write myself
into a hole
every day and see if i can dig the
characters out the next day
look at me i'm the last person standing
[Applause]
hold on to me for dear life
you